all right with the recent advances in
AGI notably the qar algorithm by open AI
I thought we dive into a little bit of
the background of what people suspect
that it is now keep in mind qar could
have nothing to do with anything that
we're talking about but everyone's
speculating around what that could be
and I thought it'd be good to go back to
the basics and look at what is Q
learning and you know what what is it
what does it do and how has it been used
recently or not so recently namely in
this paper right here uh playing Atari
with deep reinforcement learning by Deep
Mind which was one of the first papers
that really catapulted Deep Mind to the
Forefront of everyone's attention uh so
it's not going to be sort of
state-of-the-art research today it's
more going to be a basic introduction
into Q learning I've actually done a
video on this particular paper before if
you want to know more about this paper
today it's really going to be about Q
learning in general so let's dive in Q
learning we're in the field of so-called
reinforcement learning and again we'll
keep an eye on the application how that
might apply to a language model or
something like this as we go through
this but in the basic sense in
reinforcement learning you have your
agent over here that is the ugliest a I
have ever seen so you'll have your agent
over here and you'll have an environment
and the environment is giving the agent
what's called an observation O Okay um
the agent is going to react to that
observation and uh then reply with an
action
a the environment is going to take that
action and give the agent a reward and a
next observation okay and this is the
basic cycle in reinforcement learning
this is the most basic concept uh the
agent gets these observations uh from
the environment and responds with
actions based on those observations and
the environment after the first step it
always gives a reward how good the Last
Action was now there are multiple
configurations of this um so the one
simplification we are going to to do
today let's say is that we're going to
say the observation is always equal to
the state um this is so-called markovian
fully fully observable um decision
process and that's just going to
simplify things a lot so when we say
observation or when we say state today
will mean the same thing think of a
chessboard You observe the chessboard as
it is okay here is maybe a simplified
chess board You observe that you know
the The Rook is here and the queen is
here and so on You observe it once and
that's everything you need to know
that's the whole state of the game
there's nothing hidden there's nothing
dependent on something in the past which
is actually not true in chess uh whether
you can Castle or not is actually
dependent on kind of the past history
and today we'll also just ignore that so
you're in a given State and you're asked
to make it an action and that will lead
to some reward now in chess uh you
already see that that's not really true
in the colloquial sense so if I move the
Rook over here maybe that was a really
bad move maybe that was a really good
move uh it doesn't matter unless it's a
Checkmate I don't get any reward at all
right so my reward from the environment
in chess is whether I have won or lost
the game and that only happens at the
very end end of the game no matter how
good my moves are in between uh I will
not get any reward from the Environ
environment until the very last step and
that's a problem in reinforcement
learning so I can go from state to state
from step to step I can go through this
game and all and I only get a reward
here at the end now this is very tricky
situation for a system to learn because
how are you going to know whether the
move you made here was ultimately the
correct move you have a very similar uh
you have a very similar challenge when
you do like sequence to sequence
learning with language models because
first you go through a sequence right
and then you output the sequence over
here so this would be the encoded stage
and then from here on you'll decode and
as if it's as if you wouldn't get a loss
each token that you produce but only at
the very end someone would look at the
whole sentence and say well that's
pretty good or no that's pretty bad
right and in fact that you know that's
what we do when we do reinforcement
learning uh even for
RL so reinforcement learning doesn't
necessarily mean you only get reward at
the end but many environments are
structured such that only after you've
sort of completed the ENT per episode
you get a reward at the end and you need
to sort of figure out what was good and
what was bad that you done you've done
in the
meantime and Q learning is one way that
you know is is kind of good at let's say
mitigating that and doing this credit
assignment so the assignment of you know
this actually depended on oopsie
dependent on moves that I've done
before so how do we go about this
formally well let's not go too formal we
have this is called a a mark of decision
process um fully observable as we said
and that means that I'm always in some
kind of a state I take an action I go to
a next state so State one I transition
to state two by doing action one if I
did action two instead I'm going to
transition to state three um maybe from
state three if I do action one I
transition to state too and so on so I
can move around these states by
performing these actions also we're just
going to consider that you always have
the same actions available in no matter
what state you're in it's also not
entirely true but um yeah so I need to
figure out I'm in a given state right
and I need to figure out what action
should I do and one way to go about that
is to have a function that takes in a
state and gives me an action that that
is that that is possible um that is if
you do any sort of uh actor critic
reinforcement learning or something like
this policy gradient methods uh they do
this so they train they learn a function
that you input a state and it's going to
give you an action and it doesn't
explain how or why or anything like this
um today we're not going to do that
we're going to do something different we
going to say I'm going to define a
function q and what Q is going to do Q
is going to take in a
state and an a proposed action a
proposed action so you're in state s and
you're saying if I did task a what would
my total reward reward my total reward
be if I did action a so you in some
State here right you could go here you
could go here from here you could go in
many different places and at some point
da da da da da there will be end States
and in the end States this is a good one
and this here might be a bad one and you
don't know how you how you get to to
these right so you're in
state in this state here and you're
asking yourself which action should I do
should I do action one or should I do
action
two well if you had this function what
it would tell you is okay if I plug in
if I plug in A1 here let's say I plug it
in I am in state s this is State S I
plug in A1 sorry A1 this gives me
five Q of s and A2 gives me 10 obviously
I'm going to choose 10 so I'm going to
choose A2 so the Q function is a
function let don't worry how it comes
about the Q function is a function that
in current state you give it a proposed
action it tells you how your total
reward from here on out how much that's
going to be if you now do action
whatever action you plug in that is
missing a little bit of information if
you've realized that um
namely even if I do action A2 here I'm
going to be in this state I'm still
going to have options even after that
right so just because I now decide to do
A2 after that I can still and I probably
will have to choose many more times what
to do until I finally reach some sort of
good or bad end state so in order for
this Q function to be well defined I
also have to specify what I do after
that and what I do after that is is
that's called a policy so a policy and I
previously called it f um but
technically or not technically commonly
it's called Pi so Pi of s
uh this is a policy um you give in a
state s and it tells you do action
a sometimes this can be formulated in a
probabilistic manner so you can say my U
probability of doing action a given
State s can be defined as this so it's
going to give you like a uh a
probability for Action a given State s
but we can also go the deterministic
case right here and say a policy you
give it a state and it's going to tell
you go left go right go up go down note
the policy says nothing about reward the
policy is simply you could write it down
right you could make a table and say
well if you're in this state do this if
you're in this state do this
and there can be good policies which
lead to high reward and there could be
bad policies which lead to low reward in
fact policies can be kind of ordered so
you can say you know a policy is better
than policy one is better than policy 2
if in any state you can be in uh the
actions if you follow policy one you get
a better reward than if you follow
policy 2 but obviously these are not um
there not a total ordering in that sense
because for some it can really depend on
the
state but never mind so I hope you
realize the difference between a policy
a policy is simply a function that tells
you what to do and there can be good
policies and bad policies and the Q the
Q
function now we can fully Define it so
in order to fully Define a q function I
would have have to also Supply it with a
policy so usually you say this so q q Pi
of s and A1 tells you you're in you're
in state
s if you were to now take action A1 in
this state and after that do whatever
the policy Pi tells you to do then you
would get a reward of five however if
you're in the state now and do action
two and after that equally just do what
policy Pi tells you to do then you would
be in uh in a reward of 10 okay so in a
sense what the Q function tells us is
that we'll commit to following a
particular policy after this step but
for this step we don't really know what
to do so we plug each action into the Q
function say well after this step I'm
going to follow this policy right here
but please tell me what to do right now
and the Q function evaluates each action
and tells you a reward that it thinks
you know after taking this action now
and then following the policy uh you
will the total reward you'll get until
the end of the episode by the way we
haven't really specified reward and
episodes right now so in classic
reinforcement learning you always kind
of assume that the episodes go for an
infinite time Horizon um so your total
reward is going to be the reward that
you get at step one plus the reward you
get at step two plus the reward you'll
get at step three and so on now you can
see that if this goes on for an
infinitely long amount of time you can
get infinite reward uh so what people do
even in the finite Cas is people say
there's discount
Factor so plus GMA 3 R3 R4 and so on so
well okay I kind of screwed up my
indices here but we'll essentially say
you know as time progresses the rewards
are going to be worth less and less in
the now right so the if I and that's
similar to how humans perceive reward I
guess if it's further in the future it's
worth less to me now okay it's going to
be worth more in the future obviously
but it's worth less to me now if you
promise me $100 tomorrow uh than if you
just give me $100 right now and that's
not because I'm unsure about the
tomorrow right it's just because uh I'd
like to have it right
now we can there are other discount
factors that model things like
uncertainty um either in the problem or
in our estimation of it but the basic
the basics basic total reward can be
calculated as a sum and here I'm going
to switch my switch my indices of gamma
to the I so I goes from zero to possibly
infinity or t uh of the reward I'm going
to get in that particular step okay so
this this reward here is what I want to
maximize the total reward across the
episode and as we said if if this here
if our episodes are such like in chess
that just once at the very end I'm going
to get a reward um we might as well set
the discount Factor here to just
one and because it this is going to
unroll to just the the last reward
anyway so uh actually
h I to T so this is going to this is
going to be reward
r i equals T something like this this is
not super well written is it um but you
hope you understand what I mean so if we
only get one reward we might as well and
we don't care how long the episodes are
right in chest don't care how long a
game is if I win a win doesn't matter if
it's in 20 or in 60 moves we might as
well put the discount factor to one and
just take the last reward um but in
normal regular reinforcement learning
there's discount
Factor
so why I did that it's important to
understand uh the the framing of the Q
function and we could ask ourselves
why is this five and this 10 right
picture yourself you're on a chess board
right and you have only two moves
available and you ask the Q function you
tell the Q function okay I'm I'm going
to I have like I have like
uh I don't know I have like Gary
Kasparov on the phone or Magnus Carlson
and I'm going to I I can call him after
this move right so that I'm I'm going to
this is the this is like a good policy I
know but I just need to know what I have
to do in this particular move right now
after that I'm going to call Magnus
Carlson and and he's going to tell me
whatever to to do but you know how
should I move my Rook or should I move
my queen and the Q fun is going to tell
you well if you move your Rook uh your
even if you call Magnus Carlson after
that your total rewards going to be five
but if you move your queen right now and
then call Magnus caros and your total
reward is going to be
why it's important to understand the
reason why these numbers could be
different and there could be two reasons
reason one which is probably what you're
thinking first is that well the current
action of moving the queen just gives me
a higher reward right just um actually
chess isn't really good example for this
so it could be that in a reinforcement
learning problem just the current action
two it just gives you immediate five
reward right and after that you'll go on
whereas action one gives you no reward
right now and that's why it's five
different but there is another reason
and that could that's if you're playing
chess then that for sure is the reason
mely um even though you're following the
same policy after that you will end up
in a different state if you take the two
actions so if you take action one versus
if you take action two you'll be in a
different starting state so if you're
here take action one you'll be in this
state whereas if you take action two
you'll be in this state now these
actions could be on their own relatively
neutral but because you're in a
different state you will have much less
chances of ending up in a bad or a good
State depending on the state you're in
so the Q function encompasses both of
those things like how good the current
action is in the current step and also
how good the current action is
looking ahead in the state that you'll
be in and that's going to be lead us to
the one of the fundamental um equations
recurring equations in Q learning which
is going to be the development equation
the fundamental thing here is this the Q
value in state
s of action
a and following policy Pi after so after
the next step is what's that going to be
well that's going to be the
reward of Performing action a in Step uh
action a in state s so so the immediate
reward of that step um I think before
we've gone capital r let's go lowercase
R so let's say let's say like capital r
is the total reward and that's going to
be the sum of
discounted lowercase RS okay and the
lower case are are the um rewards I get
in the individual steps okay
so the Q value is going to be what re
word do I get in the immediate step that
I'm taking right I'm going to maybe
that's zero right but there in there
could be a reward right there if I put a
Checkmate it's a one if I am in a doom
and I shoot some monster I do get actual
points right this is reward uh note that
there is no Pi is not here and that's
because Pi only matters after the next
step so that the
uh
the reward is only the current step
plus whatever comes whatever reward I'm
going to make from the state that I end
up so let's just say let's just say if
I'm in state s and I perform action a
I'm going to end up in state S Prime we
we'll understand or we'll understand or
maybe S Prime a or something like this
we'll understand that means the state
that I'm going to end up with if I am in
state s and take action
a
so the reward that I'm going to end that
I'm going to achieve in the whole rest
of the game
uh from this state well what's that
going to be isn't that just going to be
the reward in S Prime you know and then
what action am I going to take here
um I could say I can take the action
whatever Pi of S Prime is going to tell
me to
do and uh I'll do that for all the s
like for all the for all the s primes
that are coming up I hope that's clear
so in the next step I'm going to just
ask well what does Pi tell me
um what does what does Pi tell me to do
that's the ACT I'm going to take I'm
going to get some reward I'm going to
get into a new state then I'm going to
ask ask Pi again what action should I do
I'm going to take that action I'm going
to get some reward and so on so this
reward is going on until the end and
we've split up our we' split up our
problem in two parts the left part here
is not dependent on that pi and the
right part here is not dependent on the
a right here okay now we can think of
something thing and
say well actually
here sorry about the one apple pen
confusion this thing here I just I just
said well
um I have magnos Carlson on the phone
why don't I just kind of call Magnus
Carlson right now right uh and that's
that's that's one thing okay that would
just solve the problem the other thing
that I could do is I could say well if I
have this Q function
available if I have it available if I
can ask the Q function you know what
what should I do right now to get like
the best or to get their reward to get
like I can ask for a given action what
reward will I get across all the game
right for a given action right now which
means that I can define a policy
policy and we're going to call that
policy uh Pi Q for
now and the policy takes in a state and
it's going to give me an action and I'm
just going to say how about how about I
just always whatever state I'm in I'm
always going to ask my Q function what
to
do so and I'm always going to take
whatever the maximum is right they just
going to plug every a into the Q
function and it's going to tell me a
number and I will just do whatever the
highest whatever action leads to the
highest number and that is a policy
right that if I at every step just do
that just do ask my Q function uh that
is a policy because I can plug in a
state and I will get out an action now
again this Q function is
incomplete we have have to supply a
policy and here is where the recursion
comes in I'm going to tell the Q
function I'm going to what happens if
I'm going to do action a right now and
in the future I'm going to act according
to the policy where in each step I ask
you Q function what the best action is
so this it's it's I'm making it more
complicated than it is but essentially
we're defining a policy that's defined
Itself by always asking the Q function
what I should do right now if I intend
to follow the Q function also in the
future and if the Q function is actually
good then that is going to be the the
optimal policy so we call it like qar of
s is going to be I'll always select the
maximum the maximum action according to
my Q function um by following the
optimal policy after I did that
and that is called development equation
um and it gives us hints on how we can
learn these things now you have to
imagine Q learning it can be done in
many many different ways but essentially
what it boils down to is the following
so I am in a state S I ask my Q function
hey Max
a okay of
qsa I ask that it's going to give me an
action actually I only going to do that
with 1 minus Epsilon amount of times and
in epsilon amount of times I'm just
going to take some some kind of a some
kind of a random random action explore
exploit right sometimes I just want to
do something else because uh I might not
might not be the best right now so the Q
function um I don't have I did not pull
this up
correctly so imagine I don't have the Q
function now so far we've always
imagined we have this magical Q function
that just knows everything about our
problem can tell us accurately what will
happen in the future obviously if I have
that I can just always ask it you know
which of these actions is the best one
and that's precisely what we can't do if
we don't know anything about the problem
and therefore Q learning is all about
can we learn this Q function so the Q
function is now going to be
parameterized somehow and it needs to
take a state and an action and it has to
tell me some sort of some sort of an
estimate of R
right okay um imagine imagine I am in a
reinforcement learning problem right I
am here my little figure is here and I
ask it goes this way and there is I
don't know it's the dinosaur game then
it's not a person it's a dinosaur is it
but let's say there is a bird coming at
me and I ask should I uh jump or should
I duck right and these are the two
actions and let's say I choose either
one Q learning can even be performed as
as far as I'm aware you don't always
have to choose the maximum Q you can do
bit of exploration here so you have
actually performed some sort of action
and you've gotten some sort of reward of
that step now what does the Bell
equation tell us the bman equation tells
us that the
Q of Pi Q of the state s and action a
should be the reward I'm going to get um
in state s and action a plus the
discounted future reward and that's
going to be the discounted Q value um
of Q
did I discount over here I probably did
not I probably did not discount over
here um of being in S Prime a so I've
done action a I gotten i' I I've that
led to reward R maybe reward is positive
because I I ducked I got a little bit
further and that gives me a few points
and I've am in a new state S Prime the
new state is I'm ducked under here here
under the bird
okay now what I can do is um I can kind
of self regress
so Q learning can be done in multiple
ways uh the easiest thing is to have a
table literal table that says that has
the state s and the action a so it tell
it would tell me Well if you're in state
one and do action one then your Q value
is going to be five if you're in state
one do action two your Q value is going
to be 10 if you're in state two and do
action one your Q value is going to be
eight and so on okay if we don't know
anything yet we'll just fill this here
with random values now there's obviously
also a different method which you might
be more used to and that's we'll build
some sort of neural network it takes in
a representation of the state so the
state is going in as some sort of
embedded or image right here there's
going to be some sort of a neural
network and then there's going to be one
output for each of the possible actions
and then each of these is going to give
you a value there's also different
methods with neural network where you'll
have as an input the
state and you'll have actions also as an
input encoded so this part encodes the
state and this part encodes the action
and the neural network is just going to
give you one output one number however
you do it right you have to initialize
with kind of random numbers and then
what you'll do is you'll simply use your
own estimate as a Target so you're
essentially saying well whatever the Q
function is um if if I ask it what the
the Q value in this state is given
an action a right it should and
actually this here on the right hand
side isn't super correct it should uh
give me the it should give
me the same as if I take the reward I'm
actually getting by doing this action
plus the future reward from the new
state now you'll see there's action a
here action a actually needs to be
marginalized across um
action a needs to be marginalized across
this policy so this is not action a from
here um but you can kind of see the
basic
principle The Q function needs to
fulfill the fundamental recursion of
bellman which means that the Q function
in this state must somehow be the reward
I'm getting by following the Q function
plus the Q function from the next state
onwards and even if I don't know the Q
function yet I can kind of regress to
myself so I can even if this is a crappy
estimate as of right now and I know if
I'm in state one I do this I go here
that gave me a reward of maybe four
right then I know
aha four and8 is probably 12 so this
here I really
underestimated the total r reward I'm
going to get to at the end of the
episode so I should probably change that
I should make that 12 right and if we
iterate and iterate we're going to get
better and better estimates and so that
might fluctuate and so on and that's one
of the problems of Q learning but you
kind of taking your own estimates as
targets um you combine them with the
actual rewards that you get from the
world so you always say well the reward
I'm getting plus what I estimate my
future reward is that's my target for
the total current reward and thereby you
can reduce the whole problem to just
estimating single step so the the single
step is then the reward that you get
from the world that's a real number
needs to somehow be the Q function in
this state minus the Q function in the
next state okay and you're going to
train your Q function so so that this
difference here matches the reward that
you're getting and you usually only
train one of the uh parameters here and
the other one you you kind of keep fixed
but I guess you could train both at the
same time I'm not sure that's super good
idea and that's how we get to this paper
deep Q learning considers Atari games so
Atari games lend themselves quite well
to the combination of deep learning and
Q learning because you have an input
state which is quite complex so you
can't do this with tabular Q learning
you have to do this with with neuron
Network so the input State it's quite
complex lots of pixels and so on but the
output action space isn't that big you
can go like on an notari you can go like
left right up down press a button and
that's kind of it um you have some combo
actions of all of these but the action
space is very limited and thus they can
actually do Q learning right here so you
can see here the fundamental um
equations that we've gone over the Q
function with the star is the optimal
the Q function following the optimal
policy that is if um I have my reward
from the current step plus if I follow
the if I
follow the best action in The Next Step
Forward okay and this is the actual
correct way of writing it right here I
botched that a little bit I hope this
becomes bit clear now so the the Q
function of the optimal policy is
whatever the reward next step is plus
the Q function for the optimal policy
from The Next Step on
out here is their loss function I said
the loss function is
Yi Yi being maybe they say that
somewhere
Yi let's
see ah there we go where
Yi
is
this plus this so essentially what we
what we've just seen so that their
target their target is the right hand
side here and um so the right hand side
must be equal to the left hand side
Balman says for the optimal policy this
must be true and therefore why don't we
just make it true using gradient
descent so the gradient they consider
here gradient of the loss function is
going to be
um you differentiate through the Q
function of the current state you keep
the Q function of the next state fixed
the reward is fixed anyway so therefore
you're going to take whatever you
estimate currently and make it closer to
whatever it should
be and again that includes your own
estimate of the future and that's why
it's a little bit different than like
supervised learning or or something like
this so if we think of this in language
modeling right you always have you have
a sequence of tokens and if you do auto
regressive language modeling then for
each for each token that you output
we'll start one late for each token that
you output you actually have a Target in
mind so from here you predict this but
you have a Target and then from these
two you predict this one but you have a
Target and that's why you can do
supervised learning when you do
autoagressive language modeling because
you always predict the next token and
that's a defined next token and that's
either correct or not correct um if we
talk about reinforcement learning in
language modeling it's more like where
the whole sequence is going to be
predicted first and maybe at the end
you're going to get some reward and then
you need to figure out well which of the
tokens actually were the good ones the
bad ones and so on what you should do
next and that's where currently in rhf
proximal policy optimization is used but
it could be conceivable that Q learning
can be used as well because in language
modeling we have a sequence or a partial
sequence that's the input and we can
encode those really efficiently using
Transformers um and we have a fixed set
of outputs namely our token vocabulary
even though that's quite a big set of
outputs we have a fixed set of outputs U
being the token vocabulary um that
um that defines defines our action space
so to say so Q learning is not too you
know too too far out there except that
with such um High action spaces it in my
understanding it tends to become a
little bit
brittle let's just quickly go through uh
what what they do right here they have a
few tricks up their sleeve one is this
experience replay uh so they don't just
always learn on policy but they have a
bit of a buffer of things they do so in
deep Q learning for tar they uh do
episodes they with probability Epsilon
select a random action otherwise select
an action according to the maximum of
the current estimate of the Q function
again we don't have it we need to learn
it so at the beginning it's going to be
crap but as we go on it's going to
improve and improve and improve and thus
we're going to play better and better
and better games which leads us into
states where we can explore more and
more the good paths right and if we just
explore the good paths then
um yeah technically we could explore
everything right technically we could
just run a random exploration in this
environment and then learn from that
however however
um that tends to not be too good as long
as like as long as these states are
really big so if there are many many
many states we don't just want to do a
random exploration because we with high
probability we will never reach the
interesting states and or not enough not
often enough and therefore we'd rather
already start going along the good
trajectories as we learn the Q function
right and only with a small probability
do something random so that we explore a
little bit we don't don't get deceived
by always going into what we think is
the maximum reward Direction because it
could be that you know right now I have
to do a little bit of a suboptimal move
but then there is much more reward and
that's what the exploration is is
supposed to do it doesn't work in all
environments and there have been even
books written about the deception of uh
rewards and the deception of goals and
so on notably um in even in the machine
learning field
so don't don't recall what it's exactly
called but you'll find
it uh what they do then is they execute
the action and they observe the reward
and the next image they set the next
state to be okay that's a step um they
store the
transition eventually they'll sample a
mini batch of transitions so the
transitions include the current
embedding of the state the action the
reward and then the next embedding of
the state if it's a terminal they just
set the target to the reward if it's a
non-terminal they set the target to that
Bellman recursion and then they perform
a gradient step on the loss function
that we've seen before and that's
essentially it and that's what gets you
a uh giant super duper company that's
getting acquired by Google and I mean it
takes a bit more than that but this is
really what put them on the map uh back
then so I hope this was a little bit of
a dive into Q learning uh into what it
does what it means again we consider the
Q function the Q function is something
that tells us if you did an action right
now um if you if you did
that in the state that you're currently
in what would the reward be not just now
but until the end of the
game if you follow if you commit to
follow a certain policy afterwards and
then we said well what is what if my
policy is just I'll always ask the Q
function what I should do and that led
us to the realization that hey
um yeah that's possible in fact it gives
us nice recurrence
relation that essentially says the Q
function now is simply a combination of
the reward that you'll get next step and
the Q function of Next
Step that again uh led us to a method of
saying well okay that's cool what if I
don't know the Q function well then I
can just use this recurrence relation to
learn it and learn it meaning I can
break down the whole problem of what if
the reward is like forever and there are
many steps and which is which like which
piece of reward is responsible for which
action here and so on this whole credit
assignment problem I can break it down
into just learning from single steps
because I'm always saying well whatever
else happens the recurrence relation
must be true for a single step so the
reward I get for a single step must be
the difference between what the Q
function told me last step and what the
Q function is going to tell me next step
and that I can use to learn the Q
function at least the Q function of the
optimal policy and we discussed a little
bit that initially Q learning was done
really with tabular Q values uh but more
and more as we move into modern ages it
can be done with neural networks where
you encode the state inter a neural
network and you ask the neural network
you know for each of the actions what
would the output be this could be done
by having one head um that just has an
output for each available action or by
also encoding the action and then have
uh one output also encoding the action
is going to allow us to go to a lot more
complex actions even continuous actions
and so on but we will not go over that
right now and here I hope this was at
least somewhat informative and turned
before everyone goes out and and runs
around and you know hypothesize about
qar keep in mind this this is entirely
possible this has nothing to do with qar
at all but it could so stay hydrated
bye-bye